over here
[Music]
it was a four to five decision by the
constitutional court they said he is
suspended temporarily and that they will
come to a decision by the end of
september i think this is going to be
seen by the protesters as something of a
victory they've been chipping away at
prior channel just positioned for a
couple of years now two years ago we saw
mass demonstrations when tens of
thousands of young people came out on
the streets calling for his resignation
this might placate them to a certain
extent it is certainly going to be
something of a shake-up for tonight
[Music]
these massive containers have been put
up in a ring all around government house
which is just through that little gap
there but in the last hour since that
decision has come down these riot police
who a couple of hours ago were standing
here with full battle dress on
bulletproof jackets shotguns with rubber
bullets
they've since taken that off they've
replaced their helmets with soft caps so
they're clearly a little less
wary now
[Music]
so think there's a feeling amongst the
general populace that while general
prayut and this government frankly
haven't handled things desperately well
they also don't want to return to the
sort of chaos we've been quite
accustomed to in bangkok i think what
the thing they're really focused on is
the general election which is scheduled
to happen by the middle of next year